In Top Gun: Maverick.
All of this...
is real.
These actors trained for months
to pull up to eight G's
And cameras mounted
inside of the F-18s
captured real intense flying.
Just look at the ripples
on Jay Ellis’ face.
But this shot is different
because this plane doesn't exist.
It's called The Darkstar
and it uses hypersonic technology...
a tool that's in development
by Lockheed Martin
but nowhere near ready
to be used like
Tom  Cruise's Pete “Maverick” Mitchell
does.
This scene is almost
entirely fabricated
from Tom Cruise's convincing sweating
and heavy breathing
to the impeccable VFX.
But the thing that
grounds it for me
is the sound design...
which is why I talked
to this guy.
I'm Al Nelson.
My job on Top Gun: Maverick was
to define the soundscape
for the film, from jets...
to doors...
foley...
ambiances...
motorcycles...
and all things maverick.
Expectations were high.
The bar was very high.
There wasn't a ‘good enough’
option.
It always needed to be
as best as it could be.
When Al's team first got
the mach 10 sequence...
it sounded something like this:
A blank slate with one big question.
How do you make fake flight
feel real?
What does the Dark Star
sound like?
First of all,
working backwards.
It's not an F-18.
It's not a fighter jet.
The Darkstar is
much more elegant.
It's much more advanced.
And one of the things
that was important
was for that to be
believable as well.
It shouldn't sound like a video game.
It can't sound sci-fi.
You think, of course,
of Star Wars
you know, the tie fighters
are amazing
but they're sci fi
and they used elephants
to make them.
And so we worked hard,
lots of field trips
to aircraft carriers,
cross-country trips
for jet engines and
auxiliary power units.
We are trying to tell the story
of Maverick's flight.
Everything we're hearing
and seeing
should feel as real
as it can feel
so that we're experiencing
this with him.
And Al’s job was to make sure that
the experience captured
all the intensity of Maverick pushing
the Dark Star to its limits.
It starts with sounds of technology
that we're familiar with.
So when you see Maverick launch,
he's using turbines.
We wanted it to have punch
and feel high tech.
It doesn't ramp up.
It just goes ‘ca-chunk’...
and then thrust.
Maverick gets up in the air
and as he starts passing
new thresholds...
“Increase to mach 3.5.”
...there's this subtle beep...
[movie clip beeps, high pitched]
“Increase to mach 3.5.”
..that starts a simmering build of tension.
Like Pavlov's dogs
we're being trained to know
that this tone
will keep repeating
until we get to the coveted mach 10.
But before that,
he has to go faster...
this time using technology
that most of us don't yet
have a reference for.
“Transitioning to scramjet.”
A scramjet uses
the speed of the jet...
to intake oxygen,
which ignites the fuel
as opposed to a turbine.
A turbine can only spin so fast
and can only generate
so much oxygen to
ignite a fuel.
All of that process needed
to be articulated sonically.
He kicks it in the scramjet
and then you see
the turbines close...
and you see the tube open up
in the back of the Dark Star.
At that point, you've got
this flow of air...
going into the jet system and
igniting that fuel...
and creating that rocket.
And then the plane
is on its way.
Maverick starts getting
comfortable.
“We’re feeling good.”
And the soundscape
reflects that
by becoming slightly more
subdued.
Because...
The other thing we're doing
specifically with Dark Star
is we are trying to tell the story
of his joy of being in this flight
and achieving...
that which no one has done before.
“He's the fastest man alive.”
And so there are moments
where we're just with him
as he's smiling.
The plane-focused sound design
pulls back
and other elements take
the forefront.
It's a lot of layers
but it's also it's not
necessarily accumulating.
It's alternating.
It's orchestrating.
-You know, when he says...
-”Talk to me, Goose.”
there's not a lot else
going on
because we are
with him emotionally.
You see the Dark Star go off
in the distance.
That's very much
a music moment.
So you don't need a lot from us
at that point.
And we're just a dot
and we're just a little rip
as you hear it
scan across the sky so
you can track it
and then the music drops out
very dramatically
and we cut to him...
...and it's boom.
And you feel a little bit
of shaking
and you hear that turbine
kick on
and you feel those thrusters.
Instead of having all these clips
sound fade into each other...
you feel every single cut.
One of my first interactions
with Tom
he said “The cuts have to hit.
They have to punch.”
He was very, very emphatic
about that.
And it's a style that the first
Top Gun established.
That aggressive cutting, style of
cutting from inside
and being just dialogue
and rather quiet
to banging on to the exteriors.
“Coming left!”
And it makes the cut feel aggressive.
It makes the film feel aggressive
and dangerous
and it propels us in the story.
Each of these cuts has a
unique sonic texture.
You cut to the rear and
it just bangs on
with this ripping, tearing
rocket thruster.
You see all of those currents
crossing the wings,
the jet stream.
It's such a beautiful visual.
And we wanted to put
something in there
that was tonal and special
which was the Roebling
Suspension Bridge.
So all of these flavors
allow it to be constantly changing
and constantly new...
and hopefully exciting.
To ratchet up that
building tension
Al’s team used a longtime
sound design trick...
the Shepard Tone:
an auditory illusion
where you loop a sound wave
separated by octaves...
which tricks your brain
into thinking
that it's a continually
rising pitch.
Listen to it here in
the rising turbines.
So the jet is starting to
complain a little bit
and so more tones are happening.
And yes, that
mach 9.7, 9.8...
each time it's a little bit louder,
a little bit higher.
It's that winding you up.
And then the minute he does it...
“Mach 10!
[cheers]”
Catharsis.
But just when you think
it's over...
we return to quiet.
And then we start again
with the build.
“Oh, don't do it.
Don't do it.”
“Just... a little... push.”
But this time the build
is different.
It starts with this beep from inside
the control room...
which plays off this last beep
from the Dark Star's cockpit.
When you listen to them both
next to each other
it's a rising tone and then
a falling tone.
And this subtly signals that
danger is coming.
The shepherd tone kicks
in louder
and more grating
than before.
It leaks into the sound-muted cabin.
So we know that the pressure
is building...
and it keeps building until...
[Explosion]
But you know, it took
some hard work
to get us to this final version.
Did some late nights
and long hours
but I'm very pleased
and excited with with how
it's been received
and how it sounds.
I know they did design an actual
Dark Star that he sat in.
You can see him sitting in it
and then at a certain point
it launches over our head
and that's when we get into
the magic of cinema.
That was an F-18 that they
then remapped the Dark Star over it.
And that jet was so low
that when you see the roof
of that shed blow off,
that was real.
That was an unexpected addition.
And the fact that Ed Harris
just stands there and takes it...
like that guy is
he’s something else.